[Música]
y
mi nombre es francés tengo 14 y hace
algunos años que me dedico este hobby de
la música
que no soy el prototipo de baterista
ruda hiperactiva y por sobre todo la
mujer
yo diría que soy más bien callada y que
me desquito con la batería como si fuera
un punch y curiosamente estos golpes
salen con ritmo y melodía la mayoría de
las veces el día de hoy no le hablaré de
un tema al que estaba acostumbrado a ir
en eventos como éste no le hablaré de
ciencias ni de matemáticas ni nada de
eso
primero que todo no lo haré reflexionar
sobre un tema muy común con el que todos
nos relacionamos día a día
primero que todo piensen qué harían
ustedes sin la música quien de aquí ha
escuchado música para ellos estudiar
para relajarse o simplemente para pasar
el rato todo es cierto
imaginen su vida sin esa canción que
tanto les gusta
una discoteque sin música en constante
reproducción como sería el festival de
río definido sin esa ley del filo días
aburridos no a continuación observé el
siguiente vídeo
y
a
[Música]
i
mira cómo cambia así esa es la
importancia de la música y siempre lo ha
tenido desde que se tiene registro en el
pasado los compositores como bach mozart
beethoven eran verdaderos ídolos
populares la ópera el espectáculo más
importante y más esperado tan esperado
como ahora lo hacemos con las tres
estrenos del cine las tradiciones se
transmiten de generación en generación a
través de los bardos
algunos recordarán cómo era escuchar
música hace algunos años como cuando
tenías que retroceder qué hacer con el
llamado la vis bic
cuando te queda mal te quedaba mal
grabado una canción y la escuchaba junto
a tu amigo y te decía oye pero si le
falta una parte y tú todo ese tiempo
juraba que la canción duraba hasta ahí y
como no olvidarse de ese compañero que
tenía todos los discos del mundo y era
más popular del curso mientras que ahora
con un par de clics en internet ya
tenemos el tema y el género que nosotros
queramos el siglo pasado se empiezan a
perfilar los géneros más importantes y
que hoy más reconocemos aparece el rock
el jazz el blues y se empieza a mezclar
con las baladas y los ritmos de cada
país
luego el pop el soul más tarde la música
electrónica el hip hop y hoy en día
se escuchan más los ritmos latinos
chocantes para algunos como la bachata o
el reggaetón
así ha sido la evolución mundial en
torno a la música
lamentablemente en chile la educación
musical no está tan presente esto sería
de ser el hecho de que solamente uno de
cada cuatro ustedes sabe tocar un
instrumento ya en un nivel más avanzado
cosa que en otros países es sumamente
distinto
hay que aprender a ver la música como un
arte subjetivo
tal como lo es una obra de arquitectura
o
una pintura
el otro día conversando con mi profesor
de música me contaba la gran diferencia
que hay entre la educación musical
público-privada
mientras que en un colegio privado se
está pasando en cuarto medio lo que se
está pasando en primero básico en un
colegio público esa es la diferencia
el pasado año que es seleccionada para
participar en una escuela de verano en
estados unidos llamada ver clic ahí
puede compartir con muchos niños de todo
el mundo de italia alemania argentina y
me encontré con una gran diferencia
la gran diferencia de la educación se
resalta muchísimo en la música
la cual ha demostrado ser una gran ayuda
para la capacidad de aprendizaje y
también para la tolerancia a la
frustración ya que ya que activa la
corteza frontal y occipital del cerebro
esto también ayuda al aprendizaje
emocional que hoy en día está tampoco
presente en los colegios de chile por
ejemplo por la llamada
prueba de selección universitaria que
tanto le tenemos miedo y me incluyo
donde solamente se evalúan los
cognitivos pero los lógicos donde queda
la constante práctica y el sentido
lúdico que nos entrega a la ocasión
musical son una muy buena escuela para
otros esfuerzos de la vida
y la música no solamente nos estrés nos
entrega aprendizaje sino que también una
integración una integración social
solamente porque te guste
en la música electrónica o la música
japonesa puedes conocer a muchas
personas de tu misma ideología religión
no sé
miren si ustedes me creen si yo les digo
que la música mueve el mundo y mueve a
las personas si no me creen lean estos
así de influyente la música en nuestras
vidas por eso y por mucho más la música
es vida gracias
[Música]